one of the most interesting phenomenons
of human beings is our creativity right
I mean our ability to transform the
world our ability to imagine new
possibilities our ability to probe the
perimeters of possibility remix the
present to see into the adjacent
possible with Steven Johnson refers to
as a shadow future that hovers over the
present state of things a map of all the
ways in which the present can reinvent
itself creativity is just connecting
things as Steve Jobs says and people who
go into this creative zone virtuosos of
the imagination those Technician
ecstatic technicians of the sacred
spaces of human virtuosity athletes when
they get in the zone scientists will
they have their Eureka moments musicians
artists when they enter these flow
States jazz musicians when they're
improving Charlie Mingus as he
rhapsodize --is through a tumbling
thicket of ideas with such a sharp and
vital alacrity that it can take the
breath away these flow states are
finally starting to be understood thanks
to neuroscience the part of the brain
responsible for self editing literally
goes dim so there is a sec I kind of
scrambling of the self there is a
scrambling of like the super-ego that's
trying to like correct everything you do
and censor and filter what is otherwise
collective subconscious active
imagination so to speak and I think that
these artists these athletes when they
go into the flow state you know I'm sure
that they they've had their 10,000 hours
of practice and whatever their skill is
but then they go into that flow state
perfection is not just about control
it's also about letting go they shut
down their lateral prefrontal cortex
they enter the realm of the numinous the
realm of the imaginal the realm where
the dream becomes real you know that
space that headspace of flow is the
place where dreams are born